one Cristen wigs Hart as officer rhoads
in the 2011 hit comedy bridesmaids you
could see the table still cracking up
whenever we watch that scene O'Dowd has
since appeared in movies including this
is 40 and st. Vincent he also guest
starred in the HBO series girls are down
now stars in the new series get shorty
based on the 1990 best-selling novel he
plays a hitman trying to leave his
criminal past to become a filmmaker in
this preview of Sunday's premiere on
epics Oh doubts character pitches an
idea to a producer mr. Moore winner I'm
sure you're really busy but I have a
script I just know you're gonna load it
with class it's quicker if I just tell
you about it so the story takes place
and the old days in Europe and there's
this young guy an Irish guy actually and
he's in love with this beautiful girl
but he loses her because he has to go to
war and he sees some terrible and he
does some terrible by the time he comes
home looking for East when they hate to
connect so we need to find that part of
himself to remember us how to love and
then all there's funny bits that's Ray
Romano they're not seeing Chris O'Dowd
joins us at the desk hey thanks very
much for having me
so listen your character miles Daly is
someone who's trying to change his life
he's going from somebody who kills
people to becoming a filmmaker that's
right what drew you to this role you
know I don't get to play kind of tough
guys very often people see me as more of
a hugger than a fighter uh-huh yeah but
what they don't realize is that my hugs
are quite violent so it was it was kind
of tempting I hadn't read something this
sharp in a while that was also quite
funny so it was an easy one for me to
jump onto but you do have some violent
scenes there's a little violence I'm
generally the guy who's trying to make
violence not happen but I'm surrounded
by people who are very trigger-happy and
probably borderline psychotic and I'm
trying to get out of all of that to
create this new life of my family and
something more pure and so I go to
Hollywood
pure anymore taken upon a Bollywood
we're definitely poking fun at it a bit
there are elements of satire in it and I
I don't have a big problem with
Hollywood and I kind of live in LA but
it is kind of like the needy aunt in the
family how do you kind of live in LA
well I'm over embark I'm a big traveler
Charlie like yourself yeah what about
the movie with John Travolta is it yeah
I mean it's we're obviously working off
the same source material with the Elmore
Leonard book but I like to think that
our show it's it's totally quite
different it's like you visit a bar at a
different time of the week yeah so the
movie is quite sharp it's like visiting
the bar on like a Saturday night when
everybody is dressed to the nines and
they're looking their best and their
pickup lines are really working but our
show is like you visited a tree am on a
weddings day floor it's sticky
yeah fighting with your girlfriend and a
fire bill is about to arrive you can't
afford to pay it that kind of vibe what
is it like working with Ray Romano he's
terrific he's got this weird voice which
he knows are you doing a film with Aaron
Sorkin hi I am yeah or directing that's
right is he divided and directed that's
right and and have you already shot it
or you we have shot it yeah I know how
is he is a director he's terrific he's
it's definitely all about the language
he's he's very specific but it when
you're a writer that good it's kind of
nice to be told that the commas matter
the commas matter you know it's he's
coming yeah yeah he's he's very specific
about the way that a line is portrayed
and it's exactly the way that I would
like that to I mean you think that if he
knows he wrote it he knows exactly what
he meant and every pause that's right
meaning to him and therefore you know I
think them to follow that it gives you
the it gives you the security of knowing
that the words were correct in the first
like you don't correct Shakespeare
exactly you and your wife have a new
baby boy yes you describe he's the
second son right that's right you
describe the life of a father is going
from traveling in the London Underground
to the subway system in New York that's
right like on the when you have one son
it's like you've got the London on
ground and it's tough going and but a
midnight it kind of stops until 6:00
a.m. and then you can kind of recoup and
clean it but to kids it's like having
the subway where it runs 24 hours and it
always kind of smells like pace Margaret
wanted to know we ask you that we were
asking you about your your officer
character yeah thank you very much
forget shorty premieres Sunday on epics
you're watching CBS this morning